check the time that's right
its gun 15 and let me explain liberals
always accuse us on the right of not
wanting to have a conversation about
guns in the wake of a tragedy but like
all my court-appointed anger management
therapist they are stupid and wrong get
a lot of this garbage the president many
Republicans want to put up a discussion
on gun laws obviously it's infuriating
every time there's another massacre
Republicans in the NRA say now is not
the time to talk about guns
it's a favorite tactic raychel of the
gun industry to tell America that you
can't talk about changing policy right
after one of these shootings first of
all only my mom calls me Rachel ii don't
presume to know what the gun industry's
favorite things are everyone knows it's
whiskers on kittens and warm woolen
mittens clutching double-barreled
shotguns and those are just a few of
their favorite things
Jesus its gun 20 let's get to it the NRA
has already started talking about guns
and they're doing it with one of their
biggest stars
Dana lash now if you don't know Dana
lash is buckle up she is a great show
over on the blaze and she's the
spokesperson for NRA carry guard
insurance which liberals unfairly paint
as murder insurance just because it's
designed to protect you if you shoot
someone where she really shines is
spitting spicy word fire in her NRA
YouTube videos they dropped this new one
on Friday so to all you liberals who say
we never want to have this conversation
checkmate but with guns Dana's new video
is a textbook example of how to win the
gun debate here here she is with her
trusty NRA sanction blue aura and
thoughtful approach to the issues we are
witnesses to the most ruthless attack on
a president and the people who vote
and the free system that allowed it to
happen in American history yes you Talib
Dana this is the worst attack on a
president ever true four presidents have
been assassinated but there's nothing
imagine if instead of shooting Lincoln
John Wilkes Booth had written a think
piece for The New Yorker calling him
impulsive America may never have heels
now remember everyone Dana's a pro this
is an NRA ad but she knows she can't
talk to us about guns before we're good
and angry so she's got a wetter rage
whistle from the highest levels of
government to their media universities
and billionaires their hateful defiance
of his legitimacy is an insult to each
of us oh she's right how dare anyone
question our president's legitimacy
that's our thing that we do to their
presidents are you all taking notes at
home because this is how you talk about
guns you make us angry and then you show
a series of seemingly unrelated but
actually very related threats then we're
ready watch how many times Dana talks
about guns in this video
these saboteurs slashing away with their
leaks and smears their phony accusations
and gagging sanctimony drive their
daggers through the heart of our future
so they can then build their utopia from
the ashes of what they burned down
their fate will be failure and they will
perish in the political flames of their
own fires we are the National Rifle
Association of America and we are
freedom's safest place slashing
saboteurs driving daggers help george RR
martin is listening because those are
great book titles but here's what you
might have missed is those scary images
like an Tifa protesters and late-night
comedians flashed by let's replay the
part where she talks about guns rifle
yeah save right there she stuck it right
between the words national and
association that's how good she is
doesn't need to say more about guns to
make the gun argument it's like jazz you
have to listen to all the talking points
she doesn't use there's a lot of images
in that video cop cars riots kneeling
football players the city of San
Francisco they're like puzzle pieces
that clearly spell out the phrase you're
about to die see the NRA knows you don't
bring a gunfight to a culture war and
the culture war is everywhere when I
watch that video I don't even know what
I'm mad about all I know is I'm amped
and I want to send my money somewhere am
i making it easier to buy bub stocks am
i standing in the way of background
checks it doesn't matter were you
watching what I was watching we're under
attack
look with the opposition think that that
video was nearly perfect but Dana lash
is just one Dana and we know that there
are so many other threats out there that
could motivate people to support the NRA
threats that are totally gun related we
at the NRA no longer talk about guns
alone there is so much more to worry
about so much it's time we got the
jagad bags of anti flag gag order
enthusiasts to listen to say Happy
Holidays and say it 63 different times
once for each gender they want you to
recognize that these aren't dying
they're gathering in secret and planning
to attack us by stinging grapefruits are
poison oranges universities and
billionaires want to eliminate Wednesday
from the calendar we've eaten their
honey for too long and now the bees want
revenge taking our freedoms away one by
one tearing our babies from our arms and
giving them away a socialist handout
sorry what it's happening okay we are
the National Rifle Christmas volcano
grapefruit Wednesday preservation and
beet attack Awareness Association of
America and were your last line of
defense against those bees yes
opposition Earth we know their stuff we
missed so tweet out anything else you
think the NRA should be afraid of
use the hashtag at our a amorphous
threat so the NRA can morph these
threats into another powerful video
you're welcome NRA
[Music]